bonsoir merci de nous retrouver sur
france 3 alsace alors que la coop 21
démarre à paris nous aussi on s'est
intéressé aux énergies propres et
renouvelables exemple avec une
microcentrale mise au point par la
société années ces environnements de
guebwiller une microcentrale
hydroélectrique avis dro dynamique
comment ça marche regardez
la vis d'archimède vous en souvenez
normalement s'inquiètant programme du
cours de physique au collège est ce
qu'on vous a peut-être pas dit à
l'époque c'était qu'avec une grosse vis
comme celle là installé sur un cours
d'eau on peut produire de l'électricité
et c'est exactement ce qu'a fait le
conseil départemental en installant
trois de ses 10 sur l'ancien canal du
rhône-au-rhin un canal qui ne sert plus
à rien depuis des décennies une seule
vis ici nous permet de faire deux
millions de kilomètres avec une voiture
de service électrique par exemple donc
pratiquement le nombre de kilomètres que
fait le conseil départemental en italie
avec pete seuls 10 et c'est pareil on
peut alimenter l'équivalent de 1200
grand foyer avec une seule de ces vices
donc c'était dommage de perdre cette
énergie est ce qu'on voulait montrer
c'est que les petits ruisseaux font les
grandes rivières et donc davis comme
celle là le penser départementale
projette d'en installer une vingtaine
dans tout le haut rhin en revendant
l'électricité qu'elles produisent elles
doivent se rentabiliser en dix ans et
cette idée d'utiliser des vis
d'archimède elle vient aussi d'alsace
voici les ateliers de nfl ou berger à
guebwiller un industriel historique de
la région qui cherchait de nouveaux
produits ont fait les machines textiles
depuis 200 ans et donc on cherche pas d
un des nouveaux marchés avec des
produits mac sont plus d'actualité et ce
n'est pas un hasard si l'on choisit une
grosse vis en métal comme nouveaux
produits avec des ateliers d'usinage une
fonderie des ingénieurs sur place et les
six avaient déjà les compétences
nécessaires pour la fabrication de ses
centrales électriques et comme ils
vendent déjà leurs machines textiles
partout dans le monde ils ont un réseau
commercial en afrique ou en asie par
exemple dans des pays émergents qui ont
besoin d'énergie en s'il ya des rivières
avec des seuils et du débit pas mal de
18 dans la rivière on peut très bien
envisager l'installation ni d'archimède
et d'alimenter des villages qui pour
l'instant sont sans amertume l'enjeu est
maintenant de trouver les clients privés
intéressés par leur viseur l'aide bref
c'est faire connaître sur un marché où
personne ne les attendait